Dancing with the Stars is back who are
the early frontrunners plus the
Kardashians remake the Keeping Up open
but where's Robin Caitlyn a friend's
Dancing with the Stars season 25 kicked
off last night with a new roster of
celebs competing for that Mirrorball
trophy highlight for me was WWE
Superstar Nikki Bella who took down
partner our mission in civ like a boss
but she did admit to et that dancing
last night was so scary
she and Artem danced the tango and
missing from the ballroom was Nikki's
fiance John Cena but he did send his
support via Twitter she told us he's
busy preparing for a match john tweeted
a very sweet tweet when are we gonna see
the big man here in the ballroom in a
few weeks in a few weeks he's probably a
little busy yes he has no mercy this
Sunday so he's been prepping for that he
just flew him from China so once he
kicks Roman reigns bed and he will make
his way over here
what oh you were from nuki all right now
right on the gate my girl Lindsey
Stirling tied for the Knights highest
score with partner Mark Ballas I've
talked to Lindsay many times in the past
and she is as humble as they come but
now more than ever this is a million
yards out of the comfort zone like I
wasn't
everything will be dancing and he's like
your feet and I'm like oh he's like your
arm getting it your shoulder dang it
like and you're still smiling but you
know what that's why the dances with him
look so good he's tough right well okay
let's talk about him like he's not even
here he's tough but also it's amazing if
I say this is a little comfortable I
can't make it in time
he's like I know exactly why he tells me
why and suddenly because I'm on my toes
more whatever it works he just knows the
mechanics perfectly you know who else
was amazing Jordan Fisher and Lindsey
Arnold Jordan also scored a 22 out of 30
last night now he's Broadway trained
folks so he's got a little bit of an
advantage but as Jordan explained he's
got his work cut out for him yeah you
know I am comfortable performing you
know I'm comfortable in front of people
I've been doing it for 13 years and
that's something that I'm pretty
conditioned and however the the freaked
out nature of what it is that we're
doing is the fact that ballroom is it's
a thing it's its own entity to talk
sport and everything and I it's very
foreign to me I feel so uncoordinated
but the fact that she can teach somebody
that has never done ballroom before
teach them how to lead the routine is
unreal so Lindsey and Jordan are early
frontrunners but one guy who surprised
the heck out of me and could very well
be one to watch is Frankie Muniz the
malcolm in the middle' star revealed he
broke his back in an accident as a pro
racecar driver but he didn't let that or
his nerves get the best of him man that
was exciting out there I loved it I mean
I was uh definitely a little bit of a
nervous wreck all day waiting you know
anticipating what it would be like to do
it live because I've never danced in
front anyone not even like my girlfriend
has seen me dance is that part of the
reason why presumably you turned down
the show so many times I mean I heard
that this has been kind of like in the
works for a while I just I don't know
like I don't I I don't dance like I I'm
the guy who sits and watches everyone
else have fun and I'm happy to do that
so like I didn't know what I had as far
as expectations or anything but I didn't
realize I was gonna love it as much as I
do Frankie gave a modest showing on the
ballroom floor last night but that guy
is super passionate okay we'll be recap
the biggest moments from dancing every
Monday night and Tuesday morning live on
the et reality check watch page but
moving on to the Kardashians who are
celebrating if you can believe it ten
years of Keeping Up with the Kardashians
love them or hate them you kind of got
to give them props for the staying power
and I'm not gonna lie
the show is my guilty pleasure sue me in
honor of the tenth anniversary special
the kardashian-jenner women recreated
the show's season one open needless to
say the ladies have come a long way and
so have their outfits and if we hear no
you're too tall for this okay where's
Kim
[Music]
Kanan stand in my way
mom she's always great so I'm here oh
really I'm definitely the Kim Kardashian
in my family that's for damn sure
all right noticeably missing from the
gag though is Rob Kardashian and Caitlyn
Jenner Caitlyn and Kim have both gone on
the record in various interviews that
Caitlyn is still estranged from the
family since her release of her memoir
and let's just say her book wasn't so
well received by her ex wife Kris and
her former stepdaughters after Rob he is
focusing on being a father de
ten-month-old dream and I say just keep
doing that and finally in some exciting
movie news the latest poster for the new
tomb raider has been released Alicia
vikander is taking over the role and is
front and center in the great new poster
art Angelina Jolie of course first play
Lara Croft and here's when Alicia told
us last year about filling her shoes her
combat boots for me I was like well
Angelina Jolie is the icon of Laura
crook for anyone who me but the thing is
a big read into the game 2013 and you
game came out two years ago and and
and actually the the historian and the
right is for the gang won a lot of
awards and it's more of an origin
stories actually we want to and it's
together with war and we've talked about
the directaire way I love the way we did
last year but we of course gonna try and
push to make something new we'll have to
wait until March 2018 to find out just
how different Tomb Raider is when it
drops but thankfully we get the first
trailer tonight and we'll have that for
you guys over at et online.com and
tomorrow we'll also have the highlights
from the America's Got Talent finals so
be sure to subscribe to et's youtube
channel so you don't miss our interviews
with the judges and finalists and thank
you guys so so much for watching I love
you appreciate you